tú
[Música]
gracias mi título que he seleccionado
para esta primera actividad que
desarrollan mi universidad es y keegan
como fuente de innovación
mi nombre está abajo en esa diapositiva
soy médico y cirujano con especialidad
en cirugía de cáncer y cirugía
oncológica voy a tratar de resumir en
poco tiempo lo que un recorrido sería de
72 km
para disfrazar un poquito pues lo
relativo a la edad y voy a tratar de
cumplir con los objetivos del programa
que es hacerlo en un tiempo menor de 18
minutos
la idea quiero primero iniciar
haciéndole referencia a cinco elementos
que impactaron notablemente en mi vida y
que dejaron para siempre una huella de
lo que yo debería de estar haciendo para
siempre lo primero al presentar a mi
maestro de sociología y filosofía en el
tercer año de bachillerato un trabajo de
lo que él me solicitó la respuesta de
este hombre a leer mi trabajo fue la
siguiente
canché tú tienes una gran capacidad de
síntesis a mí me dejó súper impactado es
ese mensaje que me dejó el profesor
y obviamente yo lo traduzco muchas veces
en lo que nosotros podemos influir en
algunas personas cuando etiquetamos
desde primera edad esos aspectos el
segundo aspecto que a mí me dejó marcado
siempre es la gloriosa tricentenaria
universidad de san carlos porque ella
encendió en mí
todo lo que yo necesitaba para hacer
investigación el cuarto aspecto se
relaciona una visita que hice a una
galería de arte en la antigua guatemala
en la cual yo solicite la toma de esta
imagen porque yo aquí hui que nosotros
siempre debemos de tomar consejos de la
naturaleza y como notan en esa persona
que está escribiendo ahí lo que es lo
que ofrece la naturaleza pues impacto en
mí en gran aspecto ver esa imagen el
cuarto elemento para mí fue cuando yo ya
iniciaba algunas actividades de mis
innovaciones yo me di cuenta de algo
inesperado que era cuando yo puse mi
membrana
a cabo de dos días la membrana estaba
integrada quería decir que yo ya nunca
más tenía que tocar esa esa herida el
quinto aspecto se relacionó con un
correo electrónico que me envió mi hijo
acerca de este personaje que tiene
varios varios componentes este es un
personaje japonés colombiano que se ha
dedicado a promover
en el arte de que la gente se cultive
y en cuenta pues él
cuando estuvo en japón el fundó una
empresa que se ha dedicado a promover la
calidad de los viajes que uno pueda
hacer este personaje en sus es a esa
presentación de lo que era este y gb él
dijo estos aspectos y esto pues también
hay que revisarlos o sea aquí
relacionado con vida y lo que es guy lo
que es la realización de lo que uno
espera pero particularmente esto que no
soy hacerlo para mí lo que yo logré de
obtener de beneficios sino que además lo
haga participe para los demás y yo lo
recibí como un gran gran regalo porque
esos cuatro aspectos que a continuación
van a ver para mí era lo que yo venía
haciendo durante toda mi vida porque
este famoso vídeo de él y kingate i
lo recibí en este año entonces la idea
es que yo lo tomé ese regalo como la
síntesis de lo que yo había venido
haciendo durante muchos años
a la referencia de que guy es lo primero
lo que uno debe de enfatizar para que me
he preparado yo para que soy bueno que
es lo que yo puedo hacer bien la
interrelación a lo mismo va con esto que
es lo que yo amo si aparte de que yo me
preparé para obtener alguna algún
resultado pues también que que tenga yo
amor en hacer las cosas el tercer
elemento y el más importante para mí lo
que el mundo necesita que necesita el
mundo que sea beneficioso para él y
además pues si yo voy a lograr vivir de
eso de todas esas tres elementos
anteriores pues excelente ese fue el
mensaje que él nos dio
y yo tomé ese tercer elemento la misión
lo que yo había venido haciendo o sea mi
mundo estaba relacionado con este
aspecto con como yo ayudaba a que ya sea
un paciente quemado o un paciente con
alguna úlcera se recuperara
perfectamente y que no sufriera ustedes
notan la cara de ese niño en el cual por
tener un solo tratamiento ese niño no
sufría
básicamente tomando ese consejo que yo
me refería de lo que es la naturaleza
que nos puede a nosotros brindar cómo
reparar esos millones de años atrás que
ella nos ha enseñado cómo debe de
repararse una herida por ejemplo yo tomé
ese ejemplo de la naturaleza y yo es el
mensaje que transmitido a todas las
personas y a todas las conferencias que
yo he tenido oportunidad de dar cubren
menos si ustedes se acercan a ese número
uno excelente una curación es lo que
necesita el cuerpo porque la naturaleza
no quiere que le destruyamos lo que ella
ha hecho para trabajar
viene este concepto que yo lo empecé a
utilizar hace mucho tiempo o sea yo he
reconocido lo que es la creatividad pero
para mí como miran ahí el contenido de
esa movida tiene es algo vacío porque
puede hacer que la idea me viene pero yo
ya no hago nada entonces yo empecé a
adoptar mejor esta palabra innovación
innovación significa esa idea esa
bombilla vacía que pase a ser una
bombilla en acción que se traduzca en
que yo lleve a la práctica lo que yo he
pensado es así como nosotros pues
hicimos tres tipos en total son un
poquito más de cuatro
tipos de innovaciones y básicamente el
concepto primario que yo quisiera dejar
bien en la audiencia es que no se
necesita crearlo desde cero las cosas
sino como logre van a notar que yo lo
que hice fue modificar lo que la
naturaleza ha creado o sea es utilizar
lo que la naturaleza nos brinda nuestro
primer invento utilizando el trabajo de
las abejitas más de 200 millones de
estás trabajando haciendo lo mismo y
subiendo a sus pequeñas abejitas a que
vayan a obtener el néctar que es la miel
entonces mi primera invención se
relacionó con esto o sea lo que es
utilizar la fase líquida que ellas
proveen las abejitas yo la transformé a
lo que es pues una fase sólida pero esa
fase sólida estaba acompañada de otros
componentes no sólo la miel de abejas
yo agregué algunas plantas con altos
poderes antiinflamatorios y agregué
algunos químicos derivados de mi
experiencia como cirujano en que yo
quería por ejemplo combatir pseudomona
aeroginosa entonces la idea nosotros
obtuvimos esta membrana que ha sido
ampliamente utilizada tanto en seres
humanos como en los pequeños animales o
grandes animales y con mucho éxito yo he
insistido en todos los hospitales el
agradecimiento porque ellos no se
utilizan en lesiones muy extensas
tal vez una mitad del cuerpo en la que
está afectada
y ellos lo utilizan con mucho éxito
nuestra segunda innovación fue esta
membrana que tiene particulares efectos
para porque es idéntica a la piel humana
lo van a notar en la siguiente
diapositiva pero además nos ha servido
para la reparación de la superficie
ocular igual o sea lo que es piel lo que
sencilla lo que es la córnea y sus
elementos conjuntivales es lo mismo la
idea es que esta membrana es igual
histológicamente a lo que es la piel
humana como ustedes miran sólo nos
diferencia el estrato córneo que es el
de escama moss nosotros diariamente pero
de ahí afortunadamente para nosotros
tiene esto la membrana basal que otros
productos no la tienen
entonces la el cuerpo tiene que
reconstruir aparte del daño de abajo
tiene que reconstruir lo que es esa
membrana basal la idea pues se ha
utilizado ampliamente para quemaduras
así bastante de bastante profundidad
la otra membrana una membrana un poquito
más delgada tiene que ver para el
tratamiento para lesiones de menor
profundidad se comporta como un sello
que se adhiere inmediatamente segundos
después de colocar ahora yo estoy en una
nueva investigación es este es el
producto que se trata de aportar algo
que está en guatemala para nosotros
decir bueno la calidad de lo que
nosotros obtenemos acá pueda ayudar a
muchos seres humanos
la idea es que nosotros lo que buscamos
es nuevas posibilidades terapéuticas
para tratar de disminuir que los
pacientes sufran para tratar de
que no tengan ellos desfiguraciones y
hacerlo en un tiempo muy muy apropiado
con menos cicatrices este caso les va a
ilustrar a ustedes o sea así me lo
presentaron a mí y me dijeron que cuál
es tu expectativa mi expectativa es que
más o menos después de un equis número
de intervenciones tal vez tal vez al mes
mes y medio lo logres ponerle injertos
pero no es así
miren el comportamiento de esta membrana
a los 7 días como aparece bien en la
etiqueta que está ahí ya estaba
completamente epitelización eso o sea
que le evitó cirugías a ese paciente a
la idea este fue mi título que inicié
pero para mí ha sufrido este otro tipo
de secuencias la secuencia para mí fue
mi universidad me dio innovación y me
promovió el icai
algunas personas podrían decir yo voy a
partir primero de buscar michigan y
hacer una innovación alguna otra persona
no tiene este elemento no lo he
encontrado no lo ha buscado entonces
para ellos pues este motivo de mi venida
a esta plática era en llegarles esa
cifra es e iquique pero que ellos sepan
sembrar lo y sepan cómo miran a y que
tiene que regarlo no va a llegar
espontáneo si se logra esa planta que va
a floreciendo se logra obtener una gema
estos son los pasos que yo he seguido
para todos mis procesos primero lo de
abajo yo le diría perseverancia nada de
que haya un obstáculo ahí que yo no
pueda vencer yo lo debo de hacer lo
segundo hay que hacerse muchas preguntas
muchas preguntas para qué por qué tanta
facilidad tecnológica que hay ahora para
hacerlo lo otro es cómo me asocio con
personas que sean positivas que también
traten de investigar lo otro se refiere
a esto tiempo yo mi trabajo es para ir
no estoy pensando de que lo voy a hacer
para hecho de una semana si no no este
es el momento y si algo tengo que hacer
lo hago en este momento y lo último
decirles a ustedes pues vuelen alto con
lo que tengan que lo pueden hacer esta
plática yo
la he pensado y dedicado a este binomio
a mí me impactó en un viaje a
huehuetenango de la alegría de esos
niños y que se les pueda cortar en esta
aula adentro donde ellos están había un
maestro que tenía que tener que el
cuidado de cinco grados
me refiero 1º 2º 3º 4º 5º y para cada
quien darle un tipo diferente de
educación creo que debemos de revisar
este aspecto gracias
[Música]